vor gut 250 millionen jahren hat sich
eine fürchterliche katastrophe
abgespielt bis zu 95 prozent der arten
sterben aus der wohl spannendste
kriminalfall der geologie der täter
vulkanismus im heutigen sibirien doch
wie genau hat sich einen der größten
naturkatastrophen der erde abgespielt
ein forschungsteam des renommierten
massachusetts institute of technology
hat neue spannende hinweise darauf
gefunden wie das massensterben konkret
ablief und warum die gerade in der
antarktis entdeckten vulkane so
bedrohlich sind jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
eines der größten rätsel der
erdgeschichte passierte vor rund 250
millionen jahren damals besiedelten
üppige riffs den unterwasser dschungel
kopffüßler muschel artige arm füße
weh lilien und haar sterne die ozeane
die erde war bedeckt von risiken fahren
und nadelwäldern echsen meter lange
panzer lurche und schaben lebten in
ihnen fossile hinterlassenschaften
verraten uns dass die welt damals noch
in ordnung gewesen sein muss am ende des
perm zeitalters dann passierte eine der
größten naturkatastrophen der
erdgeschichte 95 prozent aller arten
wurden ausgelöscht gesteine von damals
geben hinweise darauf wie die erde
danach ausgesehen haben muss
trostlose monotonie ab und an mal eine
schnecke oder eine muschel
ansonsten war tatsächlich fast alles
leben aus gestorben vor drei jahren
hatte ein forschungsteam um m
geologen den täter des wohl
spannendsten kriminalfalls der
erdgeschichte entlarvt der vulkanismus
im heutigen sibirien sie hatten seinen
weg gefunden das alter gesammelten
gesteinsproben so exakt wie nie zuvor zu
bestimmen uran spuren machten das damals
möglich und das verblüffende das alter
des vulkangesteins fällt genau in das
zeitfenster des massensterbens die daten
von vulkanismus und dem armageddon auf
erden liegen erdgeschichtlich gesehen so
eng beieinander dass man hier wohl nicht
mehr von einem zufall sprechen kann
damit war jedoch nur ein erstes
puzzleteil zu der risiken
naturkatastrophe von vor 250 millionen
jahren gefunden wenn seit 2014 kennt man
zwar den täter doch wie genau hat der
vulkanismus in sibirien zu dem
aussterben fast alle arten auf der erde
geführt
nun wollen die selben forscherinnen und
forscher des mrt eine antwort auf dieses
große rätsel gefunden haben sie meinen
dass der vulkanismus alleine die riesige
katastrophe nicht ausgelöst haben kann
zwar sei das das heutige servieren ein
brodelnder magma kessel gewesen die erde
spiel in diesem gebiet aus hunderten
vulkan lava hinweise darauf geben uns
noch heute die schlote doch die lava die
etwa 300.000 jahre lang aus der erde
kann nach ansicht des forschungsteams
den lebewesen nicht besonders viel
ausgemacht haben sogenannte lager gänge
und jetzt kommt also mathematische
gesteins körper die paare
zum restlichen sedimentgestein laufen
geben hinweise auf die weiteren
tathergänge zu dieser zeit von ihnen
gibt es heute zahlreiche im gebiet des
heutigen oszillieren sie erstreckten
sich über eine fläche von 1,5
millionen quadratkilometern mehr als
viermal so groß wie die fläche von
deutschland also rund 357.000
quadratkilometer
diese lager gänge sind quasi die zeugen
des massensterbens und lassen die
forscher vermuten dass sich das manchmal
vor exakt 251 millionen 940.000 jahren
ins gestein fraß vorher war es nur
über das land gestreut hatte bei diesem
weg nicht so weitreichende konsequenzen
wie bei seinem neuen weg durch das
gestein selbst die energie biologinnen
und biologen glauben dass sich das
sediment aufheizte und dazu führte dass
gase ausgestoßen wurden zudem
entstanden schwelbrände da die lava
wohl auch vor kohlevorkommen keinen halt
machte verheerend die konsequenzen was
das für folgen hatte ist unglaublich
gewaltige mengen an treibhausgasen
wurden frei die temperatur stieg
weltweit um bis zu zehn grad an ein
klima schock für die gesamte erde ist
entstanden wüsten die keine grundlage
für leben lieferten selbst in den ozean
waren die folgen des vulkanismus
verheerend das kohlendioxid verband sich
mit dem wasser und löste sich als
kohlensäure
diese verhinderte die bildung von
kaltschalen und bedeutete für die
schalentiere im meer den sicheren tod
irgendwann brach dann wohl das komplette
ökosystem zusammen zu recht kann man
wohl dieses ganze szenario als
armageddon auf der erde bezeichnet
erschreckend finde ich allerdings die
parallelen zu heute
denn all diese vorgänge wiederholen
sich gerade allerdings von uns menschen
gemacht stichwort treibhauseffekt und
versauerung der meere zum beispiel ein
solches ausmaß wie damals hat was heute
alles noch lange nicht die temperaturen
werden auch in den nächsten jahrzehnten
wohl nicht um 10 grad steigen außer ja
außer die jetzt in der antarktis
gefunden lokalen bilden ein ähnlich
riesiges manchmal fällt geologisch kann
so etwas jederzeit wieder passieren aber
geologische zeiträume sind gottseidank
zehntausende hunderttausende oder gar
millionen
eine solche katastrophe droht zwar
tatsächlich aber sie wird wohl nicht in
den
100 jahren passieren doch was wir hier
habe auf der erde machen ist bedrohlich
in der arktis beschleunigt sich gerade
der klimawandel dort steigen die
temperaturen gerade doppelt so schnell
wie auf dem rest der erde und es scheint
sich weiter zu beschleunigen das alles
ist wirklich nicht gut und es passiert
jetzt wir selber verändern die erde
gerade so dass es tatsächlich von uns
ausgelöst zu einem solchen
massensterben kommen könnte
das massensterben zum ende der parkzeit
sollte uns deshalb ganz konkret eine
warnung sein denn am ende sind vor allem
wir menschen betroffen denn auch damals
sind vor allem die hochspezialisierten
arten ausgestorben und dazu gehören wir
also wenn ihr kein video mehr zu diesem
thema verpassen wollt dann drückt man
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den medien den also die auf die
glocke er hier geht es weiter mit gefahr
einer katastrophe fast 100 neue vulkan
entdeckt einfach draufklicken tag geht
es um die in der antarktis massenhaft
entdeckten vulkane
das ist wirklich etwas beunruhigend und
ansonsten ja würde ich mal sagen bis
dann bleibt dran und schaut dieses video
spannend